what spare body work infinitive and
welcome to another episode of challenged
community this is the series where you
challenge us with your craziest ideas
related to table games if your idea gets
peak we'll feature it and give it a
shout-out so make sure to leave your
comments in the comments below so a good
friend
Benedict Ola challenged us to the around
the bottle challenge where you have to
serve around the bottle placed on the
other side of the table
[Music]
[Music]
check Reno on system akin behind the
back or on to net shot from and through
the legs or on tonight shows certain
play hard
let's do Sebastian ed Watson wants us to
play with our wrong hand and do around
the net shots so let's see who can do
the most
[Applause]
Devendra Kumar Jain once it's play the
two racquets
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
demijohn Sabri suggests we should play
with a hairdryer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the next challenge is down to you guys
Cody zet wants us get three thousand
likes in this video so make sure you
give this video a like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank for watching guys if you're new to
the channel subscribe here and check out
our other videos here also if you don't
have your own pump innocently sure yeah
go to the link below